I wanted to make a New Year's resolution
to spend more time with my family and to
start seriously working out but instead
I dedicated myself to finding the best
and worst movies on every streaming
platform so you don't have to use your
brain I've done all the work for you so
without further
Ado admittedly I'm kind of mad at Amazon
right now because apparently they're
going to be adding in commercials to the
movies and shows we've been watching
that are adree and we're going to be
paying the same amount so I'm not the
biggest fan of Amazon right now but
we're here for the movies so let's get
into it the movie on Amazon Prime right
now is Interstellar this movie does
everything right the acting the
storytelling the tension building the
score and the cinematography everything
is basically perfect it's definitely the
best new story in the Sci-Fi genre even
though that little robot tars freaks me
out and there are two scenes about this
movie that I want to point out that are
especially good the first one is when
they're driving the truck through the
corn fields chasing the Drone the music
and the cinematography in this scene is
out of this world pun kind of intended
also the scene where Matthew mcon is
reading the messages from home is just
so heartbreaking as he misses out on his
children's entire lives also Matthew
mccon did an absolutely amazing job in
his role because I mean when you think
of Matthew bcon you typically think of
all right all right all right not you
know someone who's flying through space
doing these amazing dramatic sequences
Christopher Nolan really knocked it out
of the park with this movie now for the
worst movie on Amazon Prime I think it
might be saltburn I I don't really think
this is the worst movie on Amazon Prime
but everyone's talking about it so I
feel like I need to as well well it's
probably not the worst movie but it made
me so uncomfortable it's not really a
horror movie it's not really a drama
it's not really a comedy or a Coming of
Age tale it's something else entirely
and I don't really think I liked it but
I also kind of liked it if you've seen
this movie you probably know what I'm
talking about and if you haven't seen
this movie you might need to watch it
once but then never again this movie
stars Barry Keegan and Jacob all Lordi
and if you're a fan of either of those
actors then it's probably worth watching
now for the ACT actual worst movie on
Amazon Prime we have cocaine bear this
was the worst waste of an hour and 35
minutes of my life that I'm never going
to get back the premise of this movie is
that it's Loosely based on the story of
an American black bear that died after
ingesting several kilograms of lost
cocaine the gore in this movie is bad
the story non-existent the effects
dismal if you're a 14-year-old boy that
likes to pull the Wings off of flies
then you might enjoy this movie
otherwise don't waste your
time Hulu I remember when you were just
a baby there were no live sports no Rick
and Morty and definitely no good movies
just a place to watch somewhat new TV
shows and now Hulu is home to some of
the best new series out there even
beating out a lot of HBO's new shows if
you haven't watched the bear or welcome
directum you're missing out but we're
not here for TV shows we're here for the
movies and Hulu is kind of lacking in
the movie Department there's some pretty
good original movies on Hulu like prey
or Palm Springs but most of their film
content is out dated or unoriginal with
the exception of a few my personal
opinion for the best movie on Hulu is
Edge of Tomorrow starring Tom Cruz and
Emily Blunt when earth falls under
attack from Aliens no military unit in
the world is able to beat them Tom Cruz
is assigned to a suicide mission killed
within moments and finds himself thrown
into a Time Loop in which he relives the
same brutal fight and his death over and
over again so basically this movie is
Groundhog Day but with aliens and a lot
more explosions also I do like this
movie more than Groundhog Day even
though I love Bill Murray and if this
movie sounds weird it's because it is
but if you like sci-fi and you like Bill
Murray I mean Tom Cruz then you'll
definitely like this movie too also
honorable mention for Hulu is elf
starring Will farell this is definitely
my favorite Christmas movie of all time
I know it's not the best movie in a
technical sense but I just have so much
Nostalgia for it and it never fails to
make me laugh it was also directed by
John favro who's done great work at
Disney and on Star Wars shows like the
Mandalorian so it's definitely up my
Avenue also as a dad to a toddler and a
6-month-old this movie really speaks to
me in certain ways did you sleep okay
last night great I got a full 40 minutes
now for the worst movie on Hulu and
that's knowing starring Nicholas Cage I
don't really remember much of this movie
other than that it gave me nightmares
from what I remember basically this
movie is about Nicholas Cage finding
little Clues to when the world is going
to end and be hit by a giant asteroid so
obviously little fourth grader me was
terrified that an ashro was going to
come and hit the earth and kill just me
out of everybody here so definitely
don't feel like you need to watch this
it's a bit of a waste of time and it'll
give you
nightmares HBO Max I mean actually it's
just max now right okay Max is home to
some of the best and worst movies you
can find on any streaming platform I'm
looking at you flash but I had a really
hard time choosing the best movie on Max
so I went with two first up we have
Avatar 2 which is definitely one of my
favorite movies of all time even though
the first movie was basically a ripoff
of Pocahontas I still loved it so much I
I remember sitting in the IMAX theater
for the first time with the 3D glasses
on and the ashes falling down when the
tree fell over and being able to feel
the ashes in my hands basically that's
how immersive these movies can be
definitely some of the best CGI out of
any movie I've ever seen especially the
underwater scenes I mean just compare
this to the Aquaman movies it's a night
and day difference and for the second
best movie on Max we have the Batman
starring Robert patson AKA Batson
there's so much to love about this movie
I made an entire video about it if
you're interested you can check it out
I'll put it in the description below now
for the worst movie on Max we have Meg 2
the trench and I'm going to be honest
with you guys I haven't actually seen
this movie I saw the first one and Jason
STM did an okay job he's fine he's not
everyone's cup of tea he's not certainly
mine but he's pretty good at what he
does which is you know be the badass guy
that fights a giant shark and I'm sure
that's exactly what he did in the second
movie but I just have no interest in
seeing it so unless you're my dad bored
on a Wednesday night you probably don't
want to watch this movie if you've seen
it and you disagree though let me know
and I guess I'll watch
[Music]
it Apple TV plus sometimes I forget you
exist the margin between this platform's
best and worst movies is pretty small
because there's really just not much
content on here sure there's some really
good TV shows like Ted lasso and sance
but when it comes to movies it's pretty
limited so for the best movie by a very
small margin is Spirited a Christmas
movie starring Will frell and Ryan
Reynolds this movie actually made me
laugh quite a bit and I always love a
good Musical the movie had some pretty
funny songs including my personal
favorite good afternoon good afternoon
and for the worst movie on Apple TV plus
we have ghosted starring Chris Evans and
Anna De armis the synopsis for this
movie is Cole Falls head over heels for
enigmatic Sadie but then makes the
shocking discovery that she's a secret
agent before they can decide on a second
date Cole and stie are swept away on an
international adventure to save the
world it's really one of the most
predictable movies ever obviously
they're going to fall in love in the end
that's how these movies go it's not that
terrible it's just that they there's not
much content on Apple TV plus so it
doesn't have anything worse than it but
if you like Chris Evans and Anna De
armis then go ahead watch this movie you
might enjoy
it the giant Netflix isn't it crazy how
we went from ordering DVDs in the mail
from this tiny company to the biggest
streaming platform in the world I
remember getting Shrek to in a paper
sleeve when I was about 8 years old and
being the happiest third grader on the
planet for exactly 12 seconds until I
realized they had sent Madagascar Escape
to Africa and instead of Shrek still an
acceptable movie for an 8-year-old but
that's besides the point we're here to
find the best movies on Netflix and let
me tell you this was pretty tough so
instead of one I again chose two both of
which star one of my favorite actors
Timothy shalamay known for the rest of
this video only as Timmy the best movie
on Netflix is Dune definitely one of my
favorite movies of all time and it has
Timothy Shalom so you can't go wrong the
cinematography the score the action
everything about this movie was perfect
in my opinion and it really really sets
it up for the next movie and in case
you're wondering no I haven't read the
book and that's probably why I love it
so much because I don't know all the
differences between the book and the
movie where they mess things up but in
my opinion this movie is amazing and I
can't wait for Dune Part Two for the
second movie that Timmy stars in on
Netflix we have the king it's basically
like Game of Thrones but without dragons
or the eighth season so it's actually
good and it's a movie it has battle
scenes that rival like the battle of the
bastards or scenes in Braveheart and it
also has really great acting and a
dramatic core that keeps the entire
story together definitely worth a watch
if you haven't seen it and for the worst
movie on Netflix it's Morin
time no actually the worst movie on
Netflix is huie Halloween now I'm a fan
of Adam Sandler he can be a really great
dramatic actor just take a look at uncut
Gems or hustle he's done some really
great work over the past few years and
this one just really did not make the
mark Hub Halloween took all the worst
from his Goofy movies like water boy and
Happy Gilmore and put together a poorly
rich written joke of a film that would
have maybe been okay as a simple
3-minute sketch not really worth your
time unless you're bored and you really
love Adam
Sandler I have never been more thankful
for a streaming platform than I am for
Disney plus the company's ability to
completely tame my Unstoppable wild
toddler with an animated movie about
toys that come to life or about talking
cars is outmatched by none and for
Disney Plus's best movie we have
Ratatouille Pixar's magnum opus their
best work of all time while it may not
be their most popular movie I mean
they've only got one ride at Disney it's
definitely their best that they've made
the story the music and the stunning
animation are all fantastic and I can
make an entire video about this movie
alone so we'll have to say that for
another day it is amazing give it a
watch if you haven't seen it yet also an
honorable mention for Disney plus is
Hamilton this is obviously one of the
best and most popular musicals to hit
the mainstream in years and the version
we got on Disney plus was really well
filmed and edited so so it's definitely
worth watching if you haven't seen it
too now for the worst movie on Disney
plus Cars 2 This movie was completely
unnecessary it was a waste of Pixar's
resources they could have been working
on better things like I don't know
Inside Out 3 it wholly detracted from
the main character Arc between the films
for Lightning McQueen a spy Thriller
just really doesn't make sense in the
world of cars this one is my son's
favorite of the trilogy but he's two so
don't listen to what he says Cars one
and three are amazing Cars 2 sucks let's
keep
moving
now that we know the best and worst
movie on every streaming service it's
time to announce my take the most
important opinion in the world on the
best and worst of all the streaming
platforms for the best we have Hulu they
have such a huge selection some pretty
great movies and some of the best TV out
there also don't forget live sports this
platform has everything you could want
out of a streamer and for the worst
streaming platform we have Apple TV plus
there's just really not much to offer
there there's nothing too terrible but
also nothing really noteworthy that'll
pull it out of the muck and that's it
let me know in the comments if you watch
any of these movies and like them and if
you disagree with anything I said today
that's okay you're entitled to your own
wrong opinion subscribe for more and
check out this video if you want to keep
watching thanks
bye